the platypus
is definitely a strange looking animal
but its odd appearance is nothing
compared to deep sea fish
ugly dogs and every single human from
the 90s
and really its looks aren't even the
craziest thing about it
try not to mock this weirdo the platypus
makes hormones and proteins that can
save people's lives
maybe even yours also there's a
perfectly good reason for its strange
appearance
scientists have studied the duckbill
platypus's dna and determined
that it shares its genes with reptiles
birds
and mammals maybe that's why the
platypus looks like a collection of body
parts from totally different
animals stuck together but like we said
this creature
is actually even crazier than it looks
it's a mammal
that lays eggs sweats milk and hunts
using electricity
so how does a platypus sweat milk and
how can it save your life
if you want to find a platypus it's not
easy
they live in only one small part of the
world fresh water areas that flow
throughout tasmania and the eastern
coast of australia
you might want to lure it with treats
platypuses are carnivores who eat insect
larvae
worms and freshwater shrimp but why
would you want to find one
what's so great about them well for one
they're very friendly
while australian law protects platypuses
from being kept as pets
they're very social with humans who keep
them in sanctuaries and zoos
another reason you might want to get to
know a platypus is that their milk or
their venom
could save your life in fact platypus
milk could end up saving us
all australian scientists have
discovered that platypus milk has
incredible antibiotic powers
this finding could lead to cures for
drug resistant superbugs
and save humanity from a global plague
so
how do you get some well in keeping with
the platypus's general modus operandi
the way its milk comes in is of course
weird
while the females have mammary glands
they do not have nipples
platypus mothers nurse their young
through pores in their stomach
the platypus milk collects and pools on
the mother's abdomen and the babies lap
it up
another way platypuses can help humans
is with their venom
it's powerful stuff platypus venom can
kill small animals so
keep your little dog away from them and
while it can't kill people
it is excruciatingly painful researchers
have discovered that
platypus venom can help us develop new
kinds of diabetes treatments
the males keep venom in spurs attached
to their hind feet
the spurs are on their feet year round
but the venom is usually only present
during mating season
the males typically don't use their
venom to kill prey or defend themselves
against their predators which include
dogs owls and foxes they use it to fight
other males for a lady platypus's
affection now for the weird part
platypuses use electricity in their
duck-like bills to get around
there are electro-receptors in their
bills that detect the tiny electric
signals that are generated by the nerves
and hearts of their prey
when it's time to eat what they've
hunted platypuses don't have stomachs
their gullets connect directly to their
intestines
instead of teeth they have grinding pads
and they grind their food so fine
it doesn't need to be digested by
stomach acids
now for the interactive portion of our
video can you guess if the platypus has
weird feet
drumroll yes they do
while their webbed feet work well
underwater they're practically useless
on land
the webbing makes it very hard for the
platypus to walk on land
so it has to walk on its knuckles not an
easy task
the platypus spends 30 percent more
energy walking on land than it does
moving in the water
walking on its knuckles sweating milk
and storing venom in its spurs
that's what makes the platypus a crazy
[Music]
creature